أم السناتور مورفي ، فلنتحدث فقط عن
هذا القرار المقدم يوم الأربعاء والذي
من شأنه أن يربط المساعدة الأمنية الأمريكية
بتقرير في حقوق الإنسان السعودية ،
فهدفك من خلال هذا القانون هو إيقاف
المساعدة الأمنية الأمريكية تمامًا للمملكة العربية
السعودية ،
لدينا بالفعل قانون بشأن الكتاب.
لا يسمح للمساعدات الأمنية الأمريكية
بالذهاب إلى البلدان التي لا تحترم
حقوق الإنسان الأساسية ، فقد تنازلنا عن هذا
المطلب مرارًا وتكرارًا للمملكة العربية السعودية
وأعتقد أن ذلك يأتي بتكلفة كبيرة
لبلدنا ، وأعتقد أن العالم يراقب
عندما نستمر في الشعور بالراحة.  مع
الديكتاتوريين الوحشيين مثل محمد بن
سلمان أو الرئيس السيسي في مصر
يجعل من الصعب علينا الضغط
من أجل الديمقراطية وحقوق الإنسان
في جميع أنحاء العالم عندما نبيع
مستويات قياسية من الأسلحة لهذه البلدان ،
لذا فأنا لا أقترح ذلك  قطعنا
مبيعات الأسلحة ، ما أقترحه هو أننا
نرفع المستوى فيما يتعلق بما
نتوقعه من السعوديين ، ولا أعتقد
أنه من غير الواقعي أن
يفيوا بهذا المعيار إذا كنا
أكثر جدية في توقع
التقدم في مجال حقوق الإنسان مقابل
العلاقة الأمنية
نعم إنه تشريع قديم تمامًا
أليس كذلك أعني أنه أه
من عام 1961 كنت من
أشد المنتقدين للسعودية الآن أه
لبعض الوقت أريد أن  احصل على
إحساسك بالمكان الذي تعتقد أن المملكة
فيه في الوقت الحالي لأنه بالتأكيد أه
وزير الخارجية الأمريكية أنتوني
بلينكين قال هذا الأسبوع إن
الولايات المتحدة وأنا أقتبس منه هنا
ترحب بأي شيء يمكن أن يساعد في تقليل
التوترات وتجنب الصراع وكبح جماح بأي شكل من
الأشكال  أفعال خطيرة أو مزعزعة للاستقرار
من قبل إيران كان يلمح إلى
صفقة إيران السعودية بوساطة صينية ،
أم أنك لم تكن مُرحبًا بهذه
الصفقة ، فأنا فقط أتساءل أين يكون
انقطاع اتصالك مع وزير الخارجية
جيدًا ، ولا أعتقد بالضرورة أن هناك
انفصالًا.  أعتقد في الواقع أنه من
المحتمل أن يكون هذا أمرًا جيدًا للمنطقة ، وإذا كان
هناك صراع أقل بين إيران
والمملكة العربية السعودية ، فهذا أمر جيد
للولايات المتحدة
وأعتقد أنك تعلم أننا بحاجة إلى طرح
أسئلة حول
الالتزامات الأساسية في تلك الاتفاقية و
التغريدة التي أشرت إليها كانت فقط كما تعلم
أعتقد أن جهودي للإشارة إلى أن
أحد الأسباب التي تجعل المملكة العربية السعودية
تقترب من الصين هو أن الصين
لا تمنحهم وقتًا عصيبًا
عندما يتعلق الأمر بسجلهم في مجال حقوق الإنسان
و  في الواقع ، إنه يمنحهم
التكنولوجيا كما يفعلون في البلدان الأخرى
التي تسهل حملة
القمع تلك ، لذا يجب أن نكون عيوننا
مفتوحة على مصراعيها عندما نعلم
لماذا قد تقترب المملكة العربية السعودية
من الصين ، فذلك لأن الصين لا
تأتي.  مع أي قيم يسأل
المملكة
ويجادل بأنهم يتعاملون مع
الصينيين وأنهم قريبون من
الصينيين لأن الصين هي أكبر زبون لهم ،
ولا ينبغي أن يكون ذلك جزءًا من التفكير
هنا
جيدًا ، فلا شك أن هناك
علاقة اقتصادية مهمة بين
السعودية  شبه الجزيرة العربية والصين ، كما تعلم ، إذا
نظرت بعد 10 سنوات على الطريق ، فإن النفط المنتج
في الشرق الأوسط سيكون
أكثر أهمية للصين مما هو عليه بالنسبة
للولايات المتحدة ، وهو وضع مثير للاهتمام
لدينا اليوم حيث تعتبر الصين في
الأساس متسابقًا حرًا.  فيما يتعلق
بالضمانات الأمنية الأمريكية في الخليج ،
تنفق الولايات المتحدة معظم الأموال
لتأمين عمليات التنقيب عن احتياطيات النفط
ونقلها ، وتحصل الصين اليوم على المزيد من هذه
الفوائد أكثر مما تفعله الولايات المتحدة ،
لذا لا أعرف أن الأمر يأتي
خارج نطاق الصين تمامًا.  من
المتوقع أن تحصل على قدر أكبر قليلاً من
التكلفة عندما يتعلق الأمر بتأمين
منتج سيكون على مدى العقدين المقبلين مهمًا
للصين أكثر
مما سيكون للولايات المتحدة ،
إلا أنك لا تزال على دراية كبيرة بشأن
النفط  الإنتاج من هذه المنطقة ،
أريد أن أعود بنا إلى أكتوبر 2022
بعد أن خفضت أوبك بلس إنتاج النفط ،
قلت في ذلك الوقت إن الولايات المتحدة بحاجة إلى
تقييم شامل لعلاقتها
بالمملكة كما فعل الرئيس جو
بايدن في ذلك الوقت
أجرت مقابلة مع السفيرة السعودية لدى
الأميرة الأمريكية أه ريما بعد هذا
القرار
أم كثر في الولايات المتحدة وأعتقد أنني
سأكتب بما في ذلك اتهامك
للسعوديين بأن هذا
قرار سياسي هذا ما قالته لي في
الوقت الذي
حاول فيه كثير من الناس  لتسييس
هذا ولكنك تسمعه من
فم الحصان ،
فهذا ليس سياسيًا ، إنه
اقتصادي بحت استنادًا إلى خبرة 40 أو
50 عامًا من رسم الخرائط والاتجاهات ، نحن لا
ننخرط في سياسة أي شخص
نشاركه ببساطة كموازن و
عامل استقرار للاقتصاد من خلال
سوق الطاقة
قالت مباشرة من فم الحصان الذي
تسمعه هنا لم يكن هذا
قرارًا سياسيًا أه ذهبت
للحديث عن مدى أهمية
أن تكون لها علاقة جيدة
بالمملكة  الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية ، هل ما
زلت تريد إعادة تعيين بالجملة ، هل
تعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة لا ينبغي أن
تتعامل مع السعودية
جيدًا ، أعتقد بالتأكيد أنه يجب علينا
إعادة تقييم العلاقة
ولدي قدر كبير من الاحترام
للسفير الأول  الانخراط معها
بانتظام ولكني أعتقد أنه من
الخطأ تمامًا الاعتقاد بأنه يمكنك
فصل سياسة الطاقة عن
سياسة الأمن القومي ، فهم متشابكون بشدة.
لبناء مصداقية الأمن القومي والسياسة الخارجية
في جميع أنحاء العالم ، لذا فإن
هذه الفكرة القائلة بأنه يجب علينا فقط اتخاذ
قرارات بشأن سياسة الطاقة بناءً على
مقدار الأموال التي نربحها تتناقض مع حقيقة
أن سياسة الطاقة هي التي تحدد
ما إذا كان بإمكان روسيا مواصلة عملها
غير القانوني  حملة وحشية في أوكرانيا ، لذلك
لا أعتقد أنه يمكنك الفصل بين
الاثنين وأعتقد أنه من المخادع أن أقترح
أنه يمكنك اتخاذ قرار بشأن النفط
دون أي اعتبار
لتداعيات الأمن القومي
مع أقصى درجات الاحترام لأن هذا
القرار تم اتخاذه من قبل
نصف المدة وأنا أشعر أنني أريد
تقديم السياق هنا ،
كان السفير يتحدث بالتأكيد عن
حقيقة أن السعوديين لم يرغبوا في
التورط في
موقف سياسي حول تلك الفترات النصفية وكان
هذا في وقت كانت فيه أسعار الغاز  كانت
عالية في الولايات المتحدة وكان ذلك يضر جو
بايدن ونظرة الديمقراطيين